okay everyone the cigar on so as usual
if you have not yet please enter
su ID so that we know you're here in
this room
so computing me okay at the back this is
okay oh yes is the volume okay at the
back all right no one's responding yes
okay all right thank you so what I want
to do today is share a few two things
you know we're approaching the in the
courts our hope you guys looking forward
to the Thanksgiving break next week
action and I guess we're all home
viewers but those us those do that
viewing this from outside California
know that we're all feeling really bad
air here in California hope there's some
of your Washington's at home you have
better air wherever you are but what I
hope to do today is give you some advice
that will set you up for the future sort
of even beyond the conclusion of cs2 30
and in particular what I want to do
today is share view some advice on how
to read research papers because you know
deep learning is evolving fast enough
that even though you've learned a lot of
foundations of deep learning and learned
about the tips and tricks and Kari know
better than many practitioners how to
actually get deep learning algorithms to
work already when you're working on
specific applications whether in
computer vision or national processing
or speech recognition or something else
for you to be able to efficiently figure
out the academic literature on key parts
of the deep learning world will help you
keep on developing and you know staying
on top of ideas even as they evolve for
the next several years or maybe decades
so first thing I want to do is um give
you advice on how when say when I'm
trying to master a new body of
literature how I go about that and hope
that those techniques will be useful to
help you be more efficient how you read
research papers and then the second
thing is in previous offerings of this
course one request from a lot of
students was just advice to navigating a
career in machine learning and so in the
second half of today I want to share
some thoughts with you on that okay so
it turns out that
so I guess two topics meeting research
papers right and and then second career
bison machine learning so it turns out
that you know reading research papers is
one of those things that a lot of PhD
students learn by osmosis right meaning
that if you're a PhD student and you see
you know a few professors will see other
PhD students do certain things that you
might try to pick it up by osmosis but I
hope today to accelerate your efficiency
and how you acquire knowledge yourself
from the UM from the academic literature
right and so um let's say that there's
an area you want to become good at let's
say you want to build that speech
recognition or analysis terms is all for
now let's see what to build that speech
recognition system that we talked about
with the robber turn-on in the desk lamp
right this is what I read there's a
sequence of steps I recommend you take
which is first compiled lists of papers
and and buy papers I mean both research
papers often posted on archive or on TV
and Internet but also plus medium pose
yeah well maybe some occasional github
poses oh those are rare but whatever
texts or learning resources you have and
then what I usually do is end up
skipping around in this so if I'm trying
to master a new body of knowledge so you
will learn about speech recognition
systems this is what it feels like to
read a set of papers which is maybe you
initially start off with five papers and
if on the horizontal axis I plot you
know 0% to 100% read / understood right
the way it feels like reading these
papers is often oh we you know 10% of
each paper or try to quickly skim and
understand each of these papers and if
based on that you decide that paper
Mateusz it died right other other other
authors even cited and say boy they sure
got it wrong when you read it it just
doesn't make sense then go ahead and
forget it and as you skip around to
different papers you might decide that
paper three is the really seminal one
and then spend a lot of time to go ahead
and read and understand the whole thing
and based on that you might then find a
sixth paper from the citations and read
that and go back and flesh sure you
understand your paper for and then find
a paper seven and go and read that all
the way to the conclusion but this is
what it feels like as you you know
assemble a list of papers and skip
around and try to master a body of
literature right around some topic that
you want to learn and I think um some
rough guidelines you know if you read
fifty to twenty papers I think you have
a basic understanding of an area right
may be good enough to do some work apply
some algorithms if you read 50 to 100
papers in an area and they speech
recognition and and kind of understand a
lot of it then that's pretty enough to
give you a very good understanding of an
area right you you might I don't know
I'm always careful about when I say you
know you're mastering a subject but you
read fifty a hundred papers on speech
recognition you have a very good
understanding of speech recognition or
if you're interested in say domain
adaptation right by the time you've read
fifty or hundred papers you have a very
good understanding of a subject like
that
but the three five to twenty papers it's
probably enough for you to implement it
but maybe not not sure if it's enough
for you to do research or be really at
the cutting edge but these are maybe
some guidelines for the volume of
meeting you should aspire to if you want
to pick up a new area I'll take one of
subjects in CS 230 and go more deeply
into it um know how do you read one
paper and um I hope most of you brought
your laptops so what I'm going to do is
describe to you how I read one paper and
then after that I'm just going to ask
all of you to you know download the
paper online and just take I don't know
take take a few minutes to read a paper
right here in class and see how far you
can get understanding a research paper
in just minutes right right here in cost
okay um so when reading one paper so the
bad way to read a paper is to go from
the first word until the last word right
this is a bad way to when you have a
paper like this oh and by the way
actually here and tell you what my real
life is like
so I actually pretty much everywhere I
go whenever i backpack this is my actual
folder I don't wanna show this is my
actual folder of unread paper so pretty
much everywhere I go I actually have a
paper yeah a stack of papers is on my
personal reading list
this is actually my real life I didn't
bring this to show you this is in my
backpack all the time
and I think that I don't know these days
on my team at landing a on deep-lined
Rai I personally lead in reading group
where I lead a discussion about two
papers a week but to select two papers
it means I need to read like five or six
papers a week to select to you know to
present or discuss at the land area and
deeper into a meeting room so this is my
room life right and how I try to stay on
top of the literature and and I'm doing
a lot if I can find this fine if I can
find the time to read you know a couple
papers of me hopefully all of you can
too but when I'm reading a paper this is
this is how I would recommend you go
about it which is the don't go from the
first or and then read until the last
word um instead take multiple passes
through the paper right um and so you
know step one is uh read the title the
abstract and also the figures especially
in deep learning there are a lot of
research papers where so the entire
paper is summarized in one or two
figures in the figure captions so so
sometimes just by reading the title
abstract and you know the key neural
network architecture figure that just
describes what the whole papers are and
maybe one or two of the experiments that
you can sometimes get a very good sense
of what the whole paper is about without
you know hardly reading any of the text
in the paper itself right that's the
first pass second pause I would tend to
read more carefully the intro the
conclusions look carefully at all the
figures again and then skim the rest and
you know I don't know how many of you
have published academic papers but when
people publish academic papers part of
you know the publication process is
convincing the reviewers that your paper
is worthy for acceptance and so what you
find is that the abstract entering
conclusion is often when the authors try
to summarize that weren't really really
carefully to make a case to make a
really clear case to the review as for
why you know they think their paper
should be accepted for publication and
so because of that you know maybe it's
slightly not slightly unusual incentive
the intro and conclusion and after I
often give a very clear summary of
what's the paper actually about and
depending on the game just be you know
bluntly honest with you guys the related
work section is useful if you want
sometimes useful you want to do
understand related work and figure out
what's what are the most important works
in the papers but the first time you
read this you might skim or even skip
skim the related work section it turns
out unless you're really familiar
literature if this is a body of not work
that you're not that familiar with the
related work section is sometimes almost
impossible to understand and again since
I'm being very honest with you guys
sometimes the related work section is
when the author's try to cite everyone
that could possibly be reviewing the
paper and to make them feel good and
then hopefully accept the paper office
of related work sections or sometimes
written in funny ways right
and then set three I often read the
paper but um just skip the math for beat
the whole thing but skip pass it don't
make sense
you know I think that one thing this
happened many times in the research is
that I mean the papers we tend to be
cutting edge research and so when we
publish things we sometimes don't know
what's really important and what's not
important right so there there are many
examples of well-known highly cited
research papers whereas some of it was
just great stuff and some of it you know
turned out to be unimportant but at the
time the paper was written the authors
did not know every no one on the planet
knew what was important that what was
not important and maybe one example the
Lynette five paper write seminal paper
by Yamaka and part of it was phenomenal
just established a lot of the
foundations of confidence and so is it
one of the most incredibly influential
papers but you go back and read that
paper and another sort of whole half of
the paper was about other stuff right
transducers and so on then it's much
less used and so and so it's fine if you
read a paper and some of it doesn't make
sense because it's not that unusual or
sometimes it just happens that great
research means we're publishing things
at the boundaries of our knowledge and
sometimes the stuff you see you know
will realize five years in the future
that that wasn't the most important
thing after all right all that what was
the key part of the algorithm maybe
wasn't what you office thought so
sometimes it passed paper don't make
sense
it's okay to skim it initially and move
on
great unless you're trying to do a peek
unless you're trying to do deep research
and really need to master it then go
ahead and spend more time but they're
trying to get through a lot of papers
then
you know then then it's just
prioritizing your time okay and so just
a few last things and then I'll ask you
to practice this yourself with a paper
right um you know I think that when
you've read and understood the paper um
these are questions to try to keep in
mind and when you read a paper in a few
minutes maybe and try to answer these
questions whether you also strive to
accomplish and what I hope to do in a
few minutes is asked you to download the
paper off the internet read it and then
try to answer these questions and
discuss your answer to these questions
with work with your peers write with
others in the class what were the key
elements what can you use yourself and
um okay so I think if you can answer
these questions hopefully that will
reflect that you have a pretty good
understanding of the paper okay and so
what I would like you to do is pull your
laptop and then so yo there's a chip so
I think on the confident videos right on
the developer I can't have videos on
Coursera you learn the bed about well
various neural network architecture is
absurd resonates and it turns out that
there's another follow-on piece of work
that maybe builds on some of the ideas
of resinous which is called dense net
so what I'd like you to do is oh and so
wonder that kids do is actually try this
and when I'm reading a paper again in
the earliest stages don't get stuck on
the mouth just go ahead and skim the map
and read the English text we can get
through faster and maybe one of the
principles is go from the very efficient
high information content for us and then
go to the harder material later
remember it's why often I'll just skim
the map and I don't if I don't
understand the similar integration just
move on and then the only data go back
and and really try to figure out the map
more careful okay
so what I'd like you to do is take our
which take on wonderful let's let's try
it listen let's have you takes seven
minutes where I'm thinking maybe one one
minute per page is quite fast and search
for this paper densely connected
convolutional eunuch networks by up
that's all okay once you guys take out
your laptop's search of this paper
download that usually refined JSON
archive arxiv right and and this is also
sometimes also call this dense necks I
guess and go ahead and take once you
take like seven minutes to read this
paper and I'll let you know when the
time is passed and then after that time
I'd like you to you know discuss with
your work with the others write what you
think are the answers especially the
first two because the other two you can
leave off but once you go ahead and take
a few minutes to do that now and then
I'll let you know when sort of like
seven minutes have passed and then you
can discuss your answers of these with
your friends
all right guys so anyone with any
thoughts or insights surprises or
thoughts from this so now you spent
eleven minutes on this paper right seven
minutes reading four minutes discussing
we're just really really short period of
time but any any thoughts what do you
think of the paper
yo-yo just spent a lot of time saying
all stuff to each other what do people
think of the time you spend trying to
read the paper actually they should tell
you how I should raise your hand if you
you know you kind of understood the main
concepts in and actually depressing of
the figures
Wow people are really less than
energetic today unusual so I think this
is one of those papers where um the the
paper is almost entirely summarized in
figures 1 & 2 I think of you a lot they
would not be if you look at figure 1 in
the caption there in Figure 2 on page 3
and the caption there and understand
those two figures those really convey
you know 80% of the idea of the paper
right and I think that a a couple of
other tips so it turns out that as you
read these papers what practice you do
get faster so for example table 1 on
page 4 right you know this mess of the
table on top this is a pretty common
format or a format like this is how a
lot of authors use to describe their
network architecture especially in
computer vision so one of the things you
find as well is that the first time you
see something like table 1 it just looks
really complicated but by the time
you've read a few papers in the similar
format you can look at able one and go
oh yep got it you know this is this is
this is the dense net 121 for suggest
and 169 architecture and be able to more
quickly pick up those things and so
another thing you'll find is that
reading these papers actually gets
better of practice because you see
different authors use different ways or
similar ways of expressing themselves
and it gets used to that you actually be
faster and faster at implementing these
understandings ideas and I think I know
these days we're not reading a paper
like this it maybe takes me about half
an hour to took you like and I know I
gave you guys seven minutes when I
thought I would need maybe half an hour
to figure out a paper like this and I
think for a more and I find it it's not
unusual for people relatively new to
machine learning to me maybe an hour to
kind of you know really understand the
paper like this and then although I'm
pretty experienced machine learning some
down to maybe half an hour for people
like this maybe even 20 minutes
it was a really easy one but there are
some outliers so I have some colleagues
sometimes stumble across a really
difficult paper you need to chase out a
lot of references and learn a lot of
others now so sometimes you come across
a paper that takes you three or four
hours or even longer to really
understand it but but I think depending
on how much time you want to spend
probably reading papers you can actually
learn you know learn a lot rate doing
what you just did but maybe spending
half an hour per paper in our paper
rather than seven minutes right um so
all right I feel like yeah that's great
and notice that I've actually not sent
anything about the content of this paper
right so whatever you guys just learned
that was all you I had nothing to do
with it so yeah like you're off there
both you go and learn this stuff by
yourself you don't need me anymore so
just the last few comments let's see so
the other few can you ask questions I
get is uh you know where do you go the
deep learning field evolves so rapidly
so where where do you go to so if you're
trying to master a new body of knowledge
definitely do web searches and they're
often good blog holes on you know here
the most important papers and speech
recognition there are lots of great
resources there and then the other thing
you I don't know a lot of people try
want to do is try to keep up with the
state of the art of deep learning even
as is evolving rapidly and so I'll just
tell you where I go to keep up with you
know discussions announcements
surprisingly Twitter is becoming
surprisingly important place for
researchers to find it about new things
there's an ml subreddit is actually
pretty good a lot of noise but many
important pieces of work do get
mentioned there some of the top machine
learning Kong conferences are nips ICML
and I clear all right and so whenever
these conferences come around take a
look and glossary at least the title see
if there's something that interests you
and then I think I'm fortunate I guess
have friends you know both colleagues
here in Stanford as those colleagues are
several the teams that work with that
that just tell me whether there's a cool
paper I guess but I think with here
within Stanford or among with your
workplace for those of you taking this
at a CPD if you can form a community
that shares interesting papers so all
the grooves I have are on slack and we
regularly slack each other or send send
each other text messages on the slack
messaging system where you find
interesting papers and that that's been
great for me actually yeah oh and and
and Twitter
let's see ken is I fell looking at you
could follow him to this is me engine
whining right I pray don't slack up
papers as often as I do but if you look
at I don't know you can also look at who
we follow their love of could be
searches that then will share all these
things online oh and um there's a bunch
of people they also use a website called
archive sanity I don't ask much
sometimes but lots of visuals is like
that um cool so just two lost tips for
how to read papers in good good at this
so it's a more deeply understand a paper
some of the papers will have math in it
and actually if you read the oh no y'all
learn about fashion all right in the
second modules if you read The Bachelor
on paper is actually one of harder
papers you read there's a lot of math in
the derivation or vaginal but they're
papers like that and if you want to make
sure you understand in math here's what
I would recommend which is a read
through it take detailed notes and then
see if you can read arrive in from
scratch so if you want to deeply
understand the math of an algorithm like
you know fashion or more the details of
back problems
the good practice and I think a lot of
them sort of a theory their own from the
science and mathematics PhD says will
use a practice like this
we're just go ahead and read the paper
make sure you understand it and then to
make sure you really really understand
it put a put aside the result and try to
read arrive the math yourself from
scratch and you can start from a blank
piece of paper and read arrive one of
these algorithms from scratch then
that's a good sign that you really
understand it
when I was a PhD student I did this a
lot right that you know I wouldn't be
the text book or read the paper or
something and then put aside whether I
read and see if I could read arrived it
from scratch starting from a blank piece
of paper as only if I could do that that
I would you know feel like yep I think I
understand this piece of math and it
turns out if you want me to do this type
of map yourself is your ability to
derive this type of map we divide the
size of math that gives you the ability
to generalize to derive new novel pieces
of map yourself so I think I actually
learned all the math for several machine
learning by doing this and this by read
arriving other people's work that
allowed me to learn how to divide my own
novel algorithms and actually sometimes
you go to the art galleries right let go
to Smithsonian
you see these aren't students you know
sitting on the floor copying the great
artworks to create paintings you know
painted by the masses centuries ago and
so I think just as today there are
students sitting in or the DeYoung
museum or whatever every war and I was
at a Getty Museum in LA a few months ago
you actually see these art students you
know copying the work of the Masters and
I think a lot of the ways that you want
to become good at the math of machine
learning yourself this is this is a good
way to do it it's time-consuming but
then you can become good at it anyway
and the same thing for codes right I
think the simple you know lightweight
version one of learning would be to
download and run the open-source code if
you can find it and the deeper way to
learn this material is the reimplemented
from scratch it's easy to download open
sourcing and rather
it works but if you can reemployment one
of these algorithms from scratch then
that's a strong sign that you really
understood this our problem okay all
right and then longer-term advice um you
know for you to keep on learning and
keep on getting better and better the
more important thing is for you to learn
steadily not for you to have a focus
intense activity you know like all of
Thanksgiving you read 50 papers over
Thanksgiving and then you're done for
the rest of your life and it doesn't
work like that right and I think you're
actually much better off reading to a
few papers a week for the next year then
you know cramming everything right over
over one long weekend or something
actually an education where she know
that spaced repetition works better than
cramming so the same same thing same
body of learning if you learn a bit
every week in space without you actually
have much better long-term attention
then you try to cram it in a short term
so this is a very solid result that we
know from pedagogy and how the human
brain works oh so if you're able to
serve again the way I my life is my
backpack I just always have a few papers
with me I'm gonna find that I can I read
almost everything on the tablet on my
iPad but I find that research papers and
all those things where the ability to
flip between pages and skim I still find
more efficient on paper so I read almost
nothing on paper these days except for
research papers but that's just me your
mileage may vary maybe something else
will work out for you okay all right um
so let's see that's it for reading mr.
rivers I hope that while you're in CSU
30 you know but if some of you find some
cool papers of you go further for the
dense net paper and find an interesting
result there go ahead and post on Piazza
or if any of you want to saw the reading
group of other friends here at Stanford
you know encourage you to look around
class fine fine fine a group here on
campus or with among your CSU 30 calls
Basel
all of your work colleagues for those of
you taking this on SCPD so that you can
all keep you know studying so nutrition
and learning them and then helping each
other alone okay so that's it for
reading papers the second thing I want
to do today is just give some
longer-term advice on navigating a
career in machine learning right any
questions about this before I move on
all right but I hope that was useful
some of this I wish I had know when I
was a first year PhD student but oh all
right um let's see can we turn on the
lights please
oh all right so kind of in response to
requests from earlier worse citizen
earlier versions of class before we you
know as we approach the end of the
quarter want to give some advice to
housing navigator career machine
learning right so today machine learning
there are so many opportunities to do so
many exciting things so how do you you
know what what do you want to do so I'm
going to assume that most of you will
want to do one of two things right at
some point you know you want to get the
job right maybe a job that does work in
machine learning and including a faculty
position for those who have been
professor but I guess eventually most
people end up with a job I think I guess
there other alternatives but oh but then
some of you want to go on to more
advanced graduate studies and although
even after you get your PhD at some
point most people do get a job after the
PhD and and and by job I mean either in
the big company you know Ora's or a
start-up right but regardless of the
details of this I think I hope most of
you want to do important work
so um what I'd like to do today is break
you know this into how do you find a job
or join a ph.d program or whatever then
lets you do important work and I want to
break this discussion into two steps um
one is just you know how do you get a
position right how do you get that job
offer or how do you get that offer of
Admissions in the ph.d program or
admission to the master's program well
whatever you want to do and then to is a
selecting a position right there between
you know going to this university versus
that university or between taking on the
job and this company is that company
what are the ones that will tend to set
you up for success for long term
personal success and career success and
everything I hope that by the way I hope
that all these are just tactics to let
you do important work right I know this
I hope that's what you want to do um so
you know what the recruiters look for oh
and I think just to keep the language
simpler I'm going to pretend that I'm
just gonna talk about finding a job and
but a lot of the very simple things
apply for PhD programs it's just instead
of saying recruiters I would say
admissions committees right things
actually
some of this is let me just focus on the
job scenario so most recruiters look for
technical skills so for example there
are a lot of machine learning interviews
they'll ask you questions like you know
well would you use gradient descent or
battery and descend the customer batches
and what happens in the mean batch sizes
too large to small right so there are
companies many companies today asking
questions like that in the interview
process or can you explain everything
else here and that GRU and when would
you use GRU and so you really get
questions like that in many job
interviews today
and so crus is looking for m/l skills as
well as and so you often be quiz on ml
skills as well as your coding ability
and then beyond your and I think Silicon
Valley has become quite good at giving
people the assessments
to test for real skill in machine
learning engineering and the software
engineering um and then the other thing
that recruiters will look for that many
recruiters will look for is a meaningful
work and in particular you know there
are some candidates that apply for jobs
that have very young theoretical they're
very academic skills meaning you can
answer all the quiz questions about you
know what is Bosch knowing okay they're
arguing design for this but unless
you've actually shown that you can apply
this to a meaningful setting it's harder
to convince a company or recruiter that
you know not just a theory but that you
know how to actually make this stuff
work and so having done meaningful work
using machine learning is a very strong
as a very desirable candidate I think to
a lot of companies kind of work
experience I think really whether you've
done whether you've done something
meaningful reassures that you know that
you can actually do work right it's not
just economic quiz questions being
another implementer in the algorithms
that work and and and maybe um yeah and
then many recruiters actually look for
your policy to keep on learning new
skills and stay on top of machine
learning and se evolves as well and so a
very common pattern for the successful
you know AI engineers a machine learning
engineers would be the following where
if you on the horizontal axis I plot
different areas so you might learned
about machine learning learn about deep
learning learn about probabilistic
graphical models learn about NLP learn
about computer vision and so on for
other areas of AI or machine learning
and at the vertical area if the vertical
axis is death a lot of strongest
candidates or jobs are t-shaped
individuals meaning that you have a
broad understanding of many different
topics in AI machine
and very deep understanding in you know
maybe at least one area maybe more than
one area and so I think by taking sis to
30 and doing the things that are doing
here hopefully you're harming a deeper
understanding of one of these areas of
deep learning in particular but the
other thing that even you know deepens
your knowledge in one area will be the
projects you work on the open source
contributions you make right whether or
not you've done research and maybe
whether or not you've done an internship
and I think these two elements you know
broad area of skills and then also going
deeper to do a meaningful project and
deep learning or work of a Stanford
professor right and do a meaningful
research projects or make some
contributions the open source publishing
on github and then let's use it these
are the things that let you deepen your
knowledge and convince recruiters that
you both have the broad technical skills
and when called on you're able to apply
these in a meaningful way to an
important problem right and in fact them
the way we design CS 230 is actually a
microcosm of this where you know you
learned about neural nets learned about
tapas at bash norm confidence sequence
models write them to say your Arlen's so
actually if a breath within the field of
deep learning and then what happens is
know then and the reason want you to
work on the project is so that you can
pick one of these areas and maybe go
deep and build a meaningful project in
one of these areas which will much more
and it's not just about making a resume
look good right it's about giving you
the practical experience to make sure
you actually know how to make these
things work and give you the learnings
to make sure that you actually know how
to make a CNN work on our network and
then constants the many students also
listed practice on the resumes obviously
so I think the
let's see the failure modes the things
bad ways to navigate your career um
there are some students that just do
this right there are some time for
students that just take class off the
class off the cars off the cross and go
equally in depth in a huge range of
areas and this is not terrible you can
actually still get a job
you still get sometimes you can even get
into some PhD programs like this without
the Deaf but this is not the best way to
navigate your career right so there are
some Stanford's issues that take tons of
classes even get a good GPA doing that
but do nothing else and this is not
terrible but this is this is not this is
not great it's not as good as the
alternative um there's one other thing
I've seen Stanford students do which is
just try to do that
right but she's just try to jump in on
day one and go really really deep in one
area and again this has its own
challenges
I guess you know one one one one failure
mode 1 mode there's actually not great
is sometimes where you get some
undergrad freshman at Stanford that have
not yet learned a lot about coding or
software engineering or machine learning
and try to jump into a research project
right away this turns out not be very
efficient because it turns out Stanford
courses are you know online courses the
Stanford classes they're very efficient
way for you to learn about the program
chip areas and after that going deeper
and getting experience in one vertical
area then defense is knowledge make sure
you know how to actually make those
ideas work so I do see sometimes
unfortunately you know send some time
for freshmen join us already know how
the code and have implemented you know
some learning Avram's but some students
that do not yet have much experience try
to jump in the research project right
away and that turns out not to be very
productive for the student or for the
research group because until you've
taken classes and master basics is
difficult to understand what's really
going on in the advanced projects right
so I would I would say this is actually
worse than that right this is this is
actually okay this is actually pretty
bad this is III would not do this for
your career
and then the other not so grateful that
you see some sandwiches to do is get a
lot of breath and then do a tiny project
here and do a tiny project in there I do
a tiny project there do a tiny project
there and you end up with ten tiny
projects but know one or two really
significant projects and again this is
not terrible but you know beyond a
certain point by the way
recruiters are not impressed by volume
right so having done ten lane projects
is actually not impressive not nearly as
impressive as doing one great project or
two great projects and again there's
more to life than impressing recruiters
but recruits is very rational and the
reason recruiters are less impressed by
someone whose profile looks like this is
because they're actually probably
factually less skilled and less able and
doing good work and machine learning
compared to someone that that has done a
substantive project and knows what it
takes to see see the whole thing through
that make sense so when I say you know
recruit is more or less empresas because
they're actually quite rational in terms
of trying to understand how good you are
at that doing important work or building
meaningful
AR systems and so in terms of building
up of the horizontal piece and vertical
piece this is what I recommend to build
the horizontal piece lot of this is
about building foundational skills and
it turns out coursework is a very
efficient way to do this you know in
these courses right you know various
instructors like us but many other
Stanford professors for the lot of work
and to organizing the content to make it
efficient for you to learn this material
and then also reading research papers
which we just talked about having a
community will help you and then that is
often building a more deep
and relevant project and and and if the
product projects had to be relevant so
you know if you want to build a career
machine learning ability or in the eye
hopefully the project is something
that's relevant to CSO machine learning
or AR deep learning
I do see I don't know for some reason I
feel like a surprisingly large number of
stem sins I know I understand that dance
true and they spent a long time on that
which is fine if you enjoy dancing go
have fun
don't don't you know you don't need to
work all the time so going join the
dance crew or go on the overseas
exchange program and go hang out in
London and have fun but those things do
not ask directly contribute to this
right yeah I know I think I think in an
earlier version in this presentation you
know students walked away saying huh you
know Andrew says we should not have fun
and work all the time and that's not to
go
um all right there is one all right um
you know there is the Saturday morning
problem which all of you will face right
which is every week including this week
on Saturday morning you have a choice
you can read the paper or work on
research or work on open source or I
don't know what people do or you can
watch TV or something um and you will
face this choice but maybe every
Saturday you know for the rest of your
life or for Law Saturdays in the rest of
your life and um you know you can build
out that foundational skills go deep or
go have fun and you should have fun all
right it's for the record but one of the
problems that a lot of people face is
that even if you spend all Saturday and
all Sunday reading a research paper you
know the following Monday or maybe spent
all Saturday and Sunday working hard it
turns out that the following Monday
you're not that much better at deep
learning is that yeah you work really
hard so you read five papers you know
great but if you work of a research
group the professor or you you know or
your manager if you're in the company
they have no idea how hard you work so
there's no one to come by and say oh
good job working so how long we can so
no one knows these sacrifices you may
all weekend to study your code open
Sol's opposes this no one knows so
there's almost no short-term reward to
doing these things but the seat but and
and where whereas they might be short
term rewards to doing other things right
but the secret to this is
that is not about meeting papers really
really hard for one Saturday morning or
for all Saturday once and then being
done the secret to this is to do this
consistently you know for years or at
least four months and it turns out that
if you read um two papers a week and you
do that for a year then you have read 50
papers after a year and you will be much
better at delivering after that right I
mean when you really you're aware the
hundred papers in the year will be two
papers a week and and so is so for you
to be successful it's much less about
the intense burst of effort you put in
over one weekend it's much more about
whether you can find a little bit of
time every week to read a few papers or
contribute to open source or take some
online courses but and if you do that
you know every week for six months or do
that every week for a year you will
actually learn a lot about these fields
and be much better off and be much more
capable at deep learning or machine
learning or whatever so yeah nobody yeah
actually my wife and I actually do not
own the TV for what I saw right but
again if you if you oh my go ahead this
is a make sure you don't don't don't
don't drive yourself crazy and and the
healthy work-life integration as well
all right so um so I hope that doing
these things
whoa it's not about finding a job is
about doing these things to make you
more capable as a machine learning
person so that you have the power to God
and implement stuff that matters and to
do stuff the - you do do do work the
matters well the second thing we like
chat about is selecting a job and
there's actually interesting um I gave
this public presentation last year
sorry earlier this year and shortly
after that presentation there was a
student in the class there was already
in a company who emailed me saying boy
Andrew I wish you had told me this
before I said to my current job
so let's see let's see let's see
hopefully this is be useful to you um so
it turns out that you know I so when
you're at some point you're on you be
deciding you know what peeps apparently
wanna apply for what companies do want
higher job ads and I can tell you what
so if you want to keep learning new
things I think one of the biggest
predictors of your success will be
whether or not you're working with great
people and projects right and in
particular you know there are these
fascinating results from whether I think
I want to say from the social sciences
showing that if your closest friends if
your five closest friends retain closer
friends are all smokers there's a much
higher chance you become a smoker as
well right and if you're five or ten
close friends are you know overweight
there's much higher chance you do the
same or and conversely there's a you
know so I think that if your five
closest friends work really hard really
long research papers care about the work
right learning and making themselves
better then there's actually very good
chance that you will be that they'll
influence you that way as well so we're
all human we all influenced by the
people around us right and so um I think
that and I've been fortunate I've told
the Stanford for a long time now is I've
been fortunate to have seen a lot of
students from go from Stanford to
various careers and because I've seen
how many hundreds or maybe low thousands
understand the students that I knew
right when there are so stem forces go
on to a separate job I saw many of them
have amazing careers I saw you know if
you have like like okay careers but I
think over time I've learned to patent
match what is predictive of your future
success after you leave Stanford only
share view some of those paths share
view some of those patterns as you
navigate your career and and and it's
just a so many options in machine
learning today it's kind of tragic if
you don't you know navigate to hopefully
maximized
one of the people that gets to do fun
and important work that helps helps
others so when selecting a position I
would advise you to focus on the team
you interact with and by team I mean you
know somewhere between ten to thirty
persons right maybe up to fifty because
it turns out that you if you there will
be some group of people maybe ten to
thirty people maybe fifty people that
you interact with quite closely and
these will be appears in the people that
that will influence you the most right
because if you join a company with
10,000 people you will not interact with
all 10,000 people there will be a corps
of 10 or 30 or 50 people that you
interact with the most and is those
people how much they know how much in
teach you how hard-working they are
whether they are learning themselves
that were influenced you the most rather
than all these other hypothetical 10,000
people in a giant company and of these
people one of the ones that will
influence you the most is your manager
alright so make sure you meet your
manager and get to know them and make
sure there's someone you want to work
with and in particular I wouldn't
recommend focusing on these things and
not on the brand of the company because
it turns out that the brand of the
company you work with is actually not
that correlated you know maybe there's a
very recall relation but it's actually
not that correlated with what your
personal experience will be like
right and so
and and by the way and getting just new
full disclosure I'm one that you know I
have a research group here at Stanford
right my research career Stanford is one
of the better-known researchers in the
world but just don't join us because you
think we're well-known right is this
just not a good reason to join us for
the brand instead you only work with
someone meet the people and evaluate the
individuals or look at the people and
see if you you think these are people
you can learn from a worker better good
people so um so in today's world there
are a lot of companies recruiting
Stanford students so let me give you
some advice and did this piece of my
good because many is well I'll just give
the advice so sometimes there are giant
companies with let's say um you know
fifty thousand people right and I'm not
thinking of any one specific company if
you're trying to guess what content
think of there's no one special company
I'm thinking of but this pattern matches
to many large companies but maybe
there's a giant company with you know
fifty thousand people right and let's
say that they have a 300 person right I
team it turns out that if you look at
the work of a few hundred presently I
team and if they send you a job offer to
join the 300 person the I team that
might be pretty good right this may be
the group you know who's working here
about the potion's papers you read on
news and so if you get a job offer to
work with this group that might be
pretty good or even better would be
sometimes even within the thirty person
the i-team is actually difficult to tell
what's good and was not there's often a
lot of areas even with this one's even
better would be if you get a job offer
to join the 30 person team so you
actually know who's your manager who
your peers who you're working with and
if you think these are thirty great
people learn for
that could be a great job offer the
failure mode that unfortunately I've
seen several Stanford students go down
or it's actually this is true sorry
there was one several years ago as a
Stanford student on you that I thought
was a great guy right you know I I knew
his work he was coding machine learning
algorithms I thought he was very sharp
and did very good work working with some
of my PhD students he got a job offer
from one of these giant companies with
that has a great AI group and his alpha
wasn't to go to the AI group his offer
was to join us and they will assign you
to a team so this book was student that
was the sample student I know about they
care about he wound up being assigned to
really um boring Java back-end payments
team and so often you accept a job offer
he wound up being assigned to a you know
back in and apologizing you work on Java
back in payment processing systems I
think that great but the student was
assigned to that team and he was really
bored and so um I think that this was a
student whose career I Percy saw his
career rising while he was at Stanford
and after he went to this you know
frankly not very interesting team I saw
his career plateau and after about a
year and a half he resigned from this
company after wasting a year and a half
of his life and missing no really on a
year and a half of this very exciting
growth of AI machine learning right so
it was very unfortunate and and it was
actually after I told this story um lost
time I told this class earlier this year
that actually someone from acquisition
from the same big company he found me
and said boy anchor I wish she told me
the story earlier because exactly what
happened to me at the same big company
oh no I want to share view a different
so so I would just be careful about
rotation programs as well you know when
the company is trying to recruit you
if a company refuses to tell you what
project you work on who is your manager
exactly what's your joining i / c do not
find those job offers data track
because if they can't you know if it
refused to tell you what team you're
gonna work with well chances are right
telling you the answer will not make the
job attractive to you that's why they're
not telling you so I just be very
careful and sometimes rotation programs
sound good on paper but it's really you
know well we'll figure out where to send
you later so I feel like I've seen some
students go into rotation programs that
sound good on paper that sound like a
good idea but just as you wouldn't after
you graduate Stanford what you want to
do for internships and then apply for a
job that would be a weird thing to do
so sometimes rotation firms out yeah
come and do for internships and then
we'll let you apply for a job and see
where when I send you and they cook your
java back and payment processing system
right so so so just just be cautious
about the marketing of rotation programs
oh and again if you do if but if there's
but but if they what they say is do
rotation and then you join this team
then you can look at this student and
say yep that's a great team I want to do
a rotation but then I would go and work
with this human and these are the 30
people I work with so that could be
great but through a rotation then it
could send you anywhere in this giant
company that I would just be very
careful at all um now on the flip side
there are some companies I'm not gonna
mention any companies but there are some
companies with you know are not as
glamorous not as not as right cool
brands um and maybe this is a only
10,000 person company or a 1,000 or
50,000 per second or whatever this is
10,000 per copy
I have seen many companies that are not
super well-known in the AI world and not
in the news all the time but they may
have a very elite team of a hundred
people doing great work on machine
learning right and there are definitely
companies whose brands are not you know
the first companies you think of when
you think of great companies that
sometimes have a really really great ten
person or fifty percent of 100 person
team that were all Sun during the
algorithms and even if the overall brand
of the overall company you know isn't as
like there's a little bit sucky if you
manage to track down this team and if
you have a job offer to join this elite
team in a much bigger company you could
actually learn a lot from these people
and do important work you know one of
the things about Silicon Valley is that
um the brand on your resume matters less
and less and less than ever before I
mean I guess I think the exceptions of
Stanford Brown you totally won the
Stanford Brown the resume but with that
exception by really your silk'n values
become really good sorry the world right
has become really good at evaluating
people for your genuine technical
schools in your genuine capability and
less for your brand and so I would
recommend that instead of trying to get
like the best stamps of approval on your
resume to go ahead and take the
positions that let you have the best
learning experiences and also allows you
to do the most important work and that
is really shaped by the you know 30 or
50 people you work with and not by the
overall brand of the company you work
with right so the variance I cross so
there's a huge variance across teams
within one company and that variance is
actually pretty bigger or might be
bigger than the variance across
different companies sense so solid and
and if a company refuses to tell you
what team you were joined I would
seriously consider just you know doing
something well if you have a better
option I would I would do something else
um and then finally yeah and and so
really again I guess I don't want to
name these companies but you know think
of some of the large retailers or
something large healthcare systems or
the lot of companies that are not
well-known in the AI world but that I've
met there a I teams I think they're
great
and so if you're able to find those jobs
and meet their people you can actually
get very exciting jobs in there right
but of course for the giant companies
that the avai teams you can join that
yielding AIT money that's also that's
also great I'm a bit biased since I used
to leave somebody's eating your team so
so I think those things are great but
but but also some teams in not all right
um lastly you know just general advice
this is how I really live my life I tend
to choose two things to work on they'll
allow you to
learn the most you know we try to do
important work so you know especially if
you're relatively early in career what
have you learned in your career will pay
off for a long time and so and so
joining the teams and working with a
great set of 10 or 30 or 50 teammates
will let you learn a lot and then also
you know hopefully I mean yeah and and
and just don't don't don't join a like a
cigarette company and help you know give
more people cancer or stuff like there
is this don't don't do this don't don't
do stuff like that but if you can do
meaningful work that helps other people
and do important work and also learn a
lot on the way hopefully you can find
positions like that that lets you set
yourself up for long-term success but
also do work that you think matters in
that and then helps other people
alright um any questions it was
important you know yeah um I think one
of the most meaningful things you do in
life is how people either advance the
human condition or help other people but
the thing is I'm nervous I don't a name
one or two things because the world
needs a lot of people who work on a lot
of different things so the world's not
gonna function if everyone works on
computational biology I think umpire is
great but it's actually good that what
people work on compile my PhD students
like you know mainly work on the outside
to healthcare my team at landing er does
a lot of work on the outside
manufacturing agriculture to some
healthcare and some other industries I
actually especially California fires
burning you know I actually think that
there's important work to be done in AI
climate change but I think that there's
a lot of them important work a lot of
industries right so I actually think
that you know I should think that the
next wave of AI sees me I should say
machine learning is we've we've already
young transform a lot of the tech well
right so you know yeah I mean we've
already helped a lot of the
circumvallate tech world become good at
AI and that's big right how build a
couple of the teams that wound up doing
this right Google brain how Google
become cognitive learning the battery I
hope I do become you know couldn't one
of the greatest companies in the world
set in China and I'm very happy that
between me and so my friends in the
industry we've made a lot of good AI
companies I think part of the next phase
for the evolution of machine learning is
fair to go into not just to check
companies like you know like the Google
and Baidu which I hope this was you know
Facebook Microsoft which had nothing to
do as well as well that was a BMP
Pinterest ruber right all these like
great companies that hope they'll all
embrace a yard but I think some of the
most exciting work to be done stores
also look outside to check industry and
to look at all the sometimes calling
traditional industries that do not have
shiny tech things because I think the
value creation there as surprised you
could implement there maybe even bigger
than if you you know yeah I mention one
interesting thing one thing I notice is
more than large tech companies all work
on the same problems right so everyone
works a machine translation everyone
Russian speech recognition face
detection at quick through rate and
probably feels like this is great
because it means there's a lot of
progress in machine translation and
that's great we do want progress in
machine translation but sometimes we
look at other industries so you know
when you look at manufacturing or how
some of the medical devices things
working ads or sometimes on these phones
hang out with farmers on
feel like in my own work my team's work
sometimes we're stumbling across
brand-new research problems that big
tech companies do not see and have not
yet done to frame so I find one most in
search of exciting challenges is
actually to be constantly on the cutting
edge looking at these types of problems
there's a different cutting edge than
the cutting edge a big tech companies so
I think some of you are joining a big
tech companies and that's great we need
more AI the big companies and the tech
companies but I think a lot of the
exciting work to do in AI is also
outside while we traditionally
considered tech all right us 10 this
whole 50s so hope I hope this was
helpful and let's let's break for today
or have a have a great Thanksgiving
everyone and we'll see in a couple weeks